- [New York] Hey.
- Hey.
- Good to meet you.
I've been dying to try this place.
I actually met the chef
once at a gallery opening
in Bushwood for me ex
girlfriend's first solo show.
He's like a video performance artist.
- Hey, sorry, traffic on the 101, ugh.
- This is Veronica.
I met her by the pool.
Is it cool if she joins us?
- Uh.
So you're from Chicago?
- Yeah, but like the actual
city, not the suburbs.
- I'm actually sitting in on
another meeting right now.
Big time investors, series A stuff.
I'm gonna have to call
you back, all right?
So, what start up do you work at?
- Mami, what do you say we go dance, eh?
- Oh, like salsa?
- No, no, no, no, Mami, no, no.
I got this place.
I can get you in with a friend for free.
Huh, mira.
Boom, boom, dali.
- Hi there.
I left my case in the pedicab.
You look really nice.
- Man, it is pouring out there.
- You should have told me
you were stuck in the rain.
I like almost left.
- Oh, I don't have a cellphone.
- Do you have any test tube shots?
- What are you doing?
- I was putting ketchup on my hot dog.
- Yeah, I'm working part time
at the Coffee Bean and Tea Leaf,
but probably not for much longer.
My web series is about to take off.
- That sounds like my friend's band.
- Would I know it?
- Oh, no, no, no, they're
really underground.
- You have to smiles.
He is super cute, bro.
Oh, that's my car, BMW, i series.
- It's freezing here.
- Really, isn't it like 70 out?
- No, it's like 65 now.
- My parents are a little conservative.
Don't let that scare you.
I am nothing like them.
- I just wish I wasn't compared
to New York all the time.
- To be honest, you're much nicer.
- Wait, you dated LA?
- Yeah, why?
- Ugh, I don't know, he's just,
he's so fake.
- Oh yeah, love New York, he's great.
- So, do you have any hobbies or anything?
(typing on keyboard)
- I have to go to the bathroom.
- So, what do you like to do--
- I'm sorry, you're so freaking beautiful.
- Maybe you wanna come back to my place.
I have this great studio in Williamsburg
that I share with only seven other guys.
- Wanna get outta here
and go to Taco Deli?
- Wait, are you not a casting director?
- What? No.
("Here Comes Trouble")
Yeah, this isn't gonna work.
- Holy shit, how did this happen?
Yo, waitress!